[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy repasamos la historia
reciente de haití una de las naciones
más pobres y más olvidadas de las
américas un país de 11 millones de
habitantes que no encuentra sosiego por
la corrupción rampante la inequidad y la
pobreza extrema y las calamidades que
les han dejado las catástrofes naturales
una mezcla que ha provocado múltiples
levantamientos populares y que hoy tiene
a haití en medio de una nueva crisis y
una ola de inseguridad y secuestros en
1804 una revuelta de esclavos liderada
por el general to sound loaded tube
convirtió a haití en la primera nación
independiente en américa latina y el
caribe y la primera en el mundo en
abolir la esclavitud siguieron cerca de
100 años de inestabilidad política y el
pago de una onerosa indemnización a
francia la primera mitad del siglo 20
estuvo marcada por la ocupación militar
por parte de eeuu entre 1915 y 1934 y
una masacre instigada por el presidente
dominicano rafael trujillo en la
frontera común de haití y república
dominicana que se calcula
cobró la vida de 20 mil a 30 mil
haitianos la violencia no se detuvo y de
1957 a 1986
los duvalier françois el padre apodado
papado y su hijo jean-claude 'baby doc'
sembraron el terror y desangraron el
erario público se calcula que sus grupos
paramilitares entre ellos los
tristemente célebres do tom makuts
secuestraron torturaron mataron y
desaparecieron a 60 mil personas de la
oposición en 1986 una insurrección
popular derrocó a jean claude duvalier
quien se exilió en francia pero su
partida no solucionó nada el poder en
haití estuvo por unos años en manos de
militares que propinaron una serie de
golpes de estado hasta que en 1990 se
llevaron a cabo elecciones y se eligió
por primera vez en la historia un
presidente democráticamente jean
bertrand arístide
arístide comenzó a gobernar el 7 de
febrero de 1991 pero fue depuesto en un
nuevo golpe militar siete meses después
en 1994 con el apoyo de 20
y soldados estadounidenses aristy fue
devuelto al poder desde donde concedió a
los eeuu futuras privatizaciones en
empresas de telecomunicaciones y aplicó
medidas neoliberales exigidas por
instituciones financieras
internacionales en 1995 arístide le
traspasó el poder a rené préval quien
fue el segundo presidente haitiano
elegido democráticamente en 200 años la
inestabilidad política la corrupción el
crimen y la miseria siguieron
profundizándose al punto que en 2004 la
onu envió un cuerpo de paz minustah que
se quedó allí por los siguientes 13 años
pero envuelta en medio de controversias
que generaron el recelo de los haitianos
frente al abono azotada durante años por
huracanes y tormentas tropicales el 12
de enero de 2010 haití sufrió un
terremoto devastador que dejó al menos
220 mil personas muertas otras 350.000
quedaron heridas y se registró un millón
y medio de damnificados el devastador
sismo agravó la aguda y penosa crisis
social el país quedó parcialmente en
ruinas
cientos de miles de viviendas edificios
gubernamentales e iglesias destruidas
para colmo desechos de una estación de
la onu contaminaron de cólera el
artibonito el principal río generando
una epidemia que cubre la vida de 10 mil
personas y enfermó a más de 600.000
después de años de negar su
responsabilidad la onu pidió perdón en
2016 pero poco ha hecho en materia de
reparación financiera desde entonces
haití intenta reconstruirse sin éxito en
noviembre de 2010 11 meses después del
terremoto se llevaron a cabo elecciones
en las cuales ascendió el músico y
político michel martelly a la
presidencia su promesa de campaña fue la
de reconstruir un país sumido en la
desesperanza en el que cientos de miles
de familias vivían hacinadas en frágiles
refugios sin servicios de saneamiento
básico pero la presidencia de martelly
sostuvo un constante pulso con el
parlamento y sus promesas de gobierno no
se pudieron llevar a cabo en 2015 se
llevaron a cabo nuevas elecciones
presidenciales marca
por denuncias de fraude el candidato de
martelly el joven empresario joven el
moisés quedó en primer lugar sin embargo
comenzaron nuevamente las protestas y
disturbios la oposición en el parlamento
alegaba fraude electoral y ante la
presión
martelly se dio el poder a un presidente
interino haití atravesó un 2016 de
crisis institucional y en octubre
nuevamente fue apaleada esta vez por el
devastador huracán matthew que dejó
cerca de 400 muertos un nuevo proceso
electoral dio por vencedor al joven el
morís quien asumió la presidencia el 7
de febrero de 2017 pero prontamente a
job en el movice le estallaron
escándalos de malversación de fondos que
destaparon la corrupción de su gobierno
y el de sus antecesores en 2019 el país
vivió otro violento estallido social el
dinero que habría servido para parte de
la reconstrucción del país más de 2 mil
millones de dólares cayó en manos de
tres gobiernos según un informe revelado
por el tribunal superior de cuentas
sobre el caso petrocaribe se trata del
petróleo venezolano subsidio
a varios países caribeños por mandato
del chavismo el país protestó
masivamente todo el año pidiendo la
renuncia de maurice pero el mandatario
se ha resistido a entregar el poder
ahora en 2021 el país vuelve a estallar
el consejo superior del poder judicial
emitió una resolución en la que asegura
que el período presidencial de moix
terminó el 7 de febrero pero el
mandatario se niega a entregar el poder
y dice que le queda un año más de su
mandato entretanto en las calles de
haití retorna la violencia la
arbitrariedad policial el crimen
arrecia ahora bajo la modalidad de
secuestros indiscriminados una crisis
que poco preocupa el mundo tras 215 años
de independencia
haití sigue más pobre y convulsa que
nunca y tan olvidada como siempre hasta
aquí llegamos soy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]